all of us are sending our love to
richard to mary and to theo and
guys you know so many of people watching
our show see richard standing in a very
dangerous place covering something
unaware that at home he was fighting
what is the biggest battle we are just
wrapping our arms around his family
everyone at nbc news had their head down
yesterday
the nbc news family emotionally pays
tribute to colleague richard engel's
late son henry savannah wrote something
really beautiful
also just to richard mary describing
them as parents she says to me
you are the personification of what it
means to be a parent on thursday the
journalists revealed on twitter that his
and wife mary's six-year-old who
suffered from rhett syndrome a rare
genetic disorder affecting brain
development had died you know when i'm
holding him and cuddling him and he
smiles back i mean what are you going to
do you have to try harder and you have
to give it everything you can back in
2018 the proud family appeared together
on the today show to discuss henry's
diagnosis where do you guys find your
strength like i'm looking at two people
and i know that you you i can see how
strong you are where's it come from
from henry yeah i mean you can't um not
get up in the morning
you just have to get up and go and do it
and
take care of him and he's raring to go
hoda first sent her condolences in a
tweet and the day after she emotionally
opened up to her today co-anchors tom
yamas and chanel jones about how devoted
richard and mary were to their little
boy i remember mary talking about how
she was caring for him how she used to
carry him in a baby bjorn all around the
house and that's how she went through a
lot of his life
and i know they're struggling but the
outpouring of support savannah guthrie
also shared a tribute of her own which
hoda read on air you are the
personification of what it means to be a
parent to love adore and delight in your
child to bring every ounce of your
beings to their flourishing you are my
heroes richard and mary made it their
mission to share their experience in
hopes of bringing awareness to the
disease and helping others doctors have
told us henry will likely never walk
talk dress himself or have the mental
capacity beyond a toddler
and that health problems are likely
coming as well
it's not a story that anybody wants to
to tell it was very difficult for us but
we wanted to raise awareness
to make other families with special
needs children children who are
challenging know that they're not alone
it can feel very lonely it's painful and
very personal but
we appreciate being able to do it and
following henry's death the couple is
making sure their son's legacy continues
richard revealed that researchers are
making progress using his son cells to
help cure rett syndrome so others don't
have to endure what they did
[Music]